Last night there was a major escalation
in this war. So the Israelis have bombed
the Iranian uh oil fields and in
response the Iranians now are attacking
the um energy infrastructure of the GCC.
Okay. So let's have a look at what this
attack looks like.
>> Hello you guys.
>> This is Qatar.
Oh my god.
Oh
>> Okay, so Qatar provides 20% of the
world's LNG.
Um, and this is a major escalation.
And again um as I pointed out last class
the entire strategy of Iran is to
destroy the global economy. Okay. And
this is how it would do so. It also
attacked Tel Aviv
in response for the assassination of
their de facto leader Ali Ali Lejani.
Okay. So this is what the attack looks
like. Um, as you can see from this
picture, this is a cluster warhead and
it is impossible for air defense to stop
this. So, Tel Aviv is getting pummeled.
We don't have footage because it's being
censored right now. And you would think
that
um the Israelis
would want this war to end as soon as
possible because Tel Aviv and other
cities are getting destroyed in this
war. And again, there's really no way
for the Israelis to defend themselves
against um Iranian ballistic missiles.
But unfortunately
there are many Israelis who are very
happy about all this destruction. All
right. And so this is one of the uh more
influential rabbis
in
Jerusalem.
He's talking in Hebrew. What what he's
saying is that this war of destruction
it will bring about the return of the
sorry not the return the coming of the
Messiah and it will happen on Thursday
which is today. Okay. So they are not at
all saddened by what is happening. In
fact they are quite animated. They're
very excited about what's happening. So
again you cannot look at this war from a
geopolitical lens. You have to look at
it from an esqueological perspective.
All right. So um let us look at
where we are in the war so far. And as
you can see it is a regional war and
both sides are seeking maximalist
objectives. And what this means is the
United States and Israel wants to
destroy Israel especially its capacity
to be a nation state. And so right now
um the Americans and Israelis are
attacking their leadership, decapitating
their leadership as well as targeting
their economy. And later on um as this
war progresses and escalates, they will
start to target in civilian critical
infrastructure including water. Okay?
And it's already happening. Um they also
want to have a divide and rule uh
strategy where they want to provoke
ethnic conflict in Iran and divide uh
Iran up into ethnic enclaves and this is
what we call bulcanization.
The Iranians on the other hand want to
destroy the entire global economy. You
do that by attacking the energy
infrastructure of the GCC because again
the entire basis of the global global
economy is cheap energy. Okay. So um as
this war progresses you will notice
certain things. All right. So eventually
the Americans will have no choice but to
launch a ground invasion.
And um one possible
attack vector is here which is Car
Island. This is where Iran stores about
9% of its oil for export. And so the
idea is that if you take Car Island, you
will uh destroy the Iranian economy and
thus its capacity to sustain this war.
The problem with Clark Island is that
it's easy to take, but it's hard to
defend because of the coastline, right?
Which case you have to also take the
coastline, but then you deal with the
Zagos mountains and so you have to
expand outwards. Okay? So this is what
we call mission creep
where you cannot justify the war. So
what you do is you put in some soldiers
and then the mission creep becomes just
justification for the war. Okay. So
that's one thing to um spot as you read
the news. Car island will be a flash
point. Another um flash point will be
Saudi Arabia because right now the
Iranians are attacking Saudi Arabia. Now
what Saudi Arabia can do is declare war
on Iran. This is important because Saudi
Arabia has a mutual defense path with
Pakistan
so that if any are attacked the other is
obligated to come to each other's
defense. Okay, this is important because
as you can see Pakistan opens up the
eastern front. Okay, so it's possible
the Americans can attack from the east.
The other the other thing that's
important is that Pakistan has nuclear
weapons
and um
um it is possible nuclear weapons are
used. I again I strongly believe tact
tactical nuclear weapons will not be
used. Okay. But once Pakistan is in the
war, nuclear warheads are now at play.
Okay. Another thing to watch is how this
war expands elsewhere. Okay. because
when the time is appropriate, what will
happen is that um the Iranians will
activate their proxies uh the Houthies
and they will close off another critical
choke point. Okay. So now what hap
what's going to happen is that there'll
be two critical maritime choke points
that are closed off thus isolating the
GCC and thus cutting off the world's
access to cheap energy. And when they do
that, we can expect global retaliation
and other forces will have to come in to
secure cheap energy. Okay. It is
possible the South Koreans, the Japanese
are forced into this war because they
are so dependent on GCC energy. All
right. All right. So these are things
that we will um uh look for in next few
weeks. Something else that is um um
creating attention on online is people
are speculating that Benjamin Netanyahu
is dead. And the reason why is that he's
he's not been seen in a public setting
for many days. There have been cabinet
meetings and Netanyahu usually cheers
them and he's not there. Okay. The other
thing is that there are fake AI videos
of him giving speeches and it's pretty
blatant. These are fake. So people are
speculating that he is dead and they're
trying to cover it up. U this is a
picture of him visiting a cafe in uh
Jerusalem to prove he's not dead. The
problem is that this cafe is in a
mountain and it will take him about like
50 minutes to drive there. So why does
he go there? Why doesn't he just have a
cabinet meeting or get on the phone with
Donald Trump to prove he's still alive?
All right. So, but I personally don't
believe he is dead. He could be hiding
somewhere um or he could be injured.
What we do know is that the Iranians are
killing a lot of senior Israeli
officials, including the head of Mossad,
the spy agency, and Na Yahoo's residence
was also targeted in Tel Aviv. So that's
so that's a really interesting question.
How the Iranians able to target so many
so so many of the top leadership of the
Israelis. Okay. But not only that, but u
this is Ali Larajani and he is the head
the de facto head of the Iran war effort
and he was assassinated
um yesterday or two days ago and the
Iranians have confirmed this. Okay. So
he is confirmed to be dead and
um people analysts are extremely worried
about this because he is a very pramatic
person and so you can negotiate with him
right so once this uh war reaches a
certain point where both sides are
exhausted then it is possible to
approach him and say you know what let's
just negotiate a ceasefire and he'd be
willing to because he's very experienced
He's also very influential. So he's able
to bring together the different um
factions of the Iranian government and
negotiate a ceasefire. With him dead, it
is now almost impossible
to foresee a ceasefire.
Okay. So let's discuss why
um you really don't want to do this sort
of stuff. You don't really want to kill
um other nations leaders. Okay. And so
you let's just use a analogy. Let's
imagine in the streets there are two
gangs at war with with each other. Okay?
Gang A and gang B. Okay? Gang A, gang B.
And if you look at gangs, they are
structured as hierarchies. Okay?
But there's a lot of autonomy among the
different sections. Okay? And what holds
uh the gangs together of course is the
leader.
So when these two gangs go to war, what
they try to avoid is killing each
other's leader. Why? Because um a war is
often used to achieve certain political
objectives,
right? And so the point isn't to kill
everyone. The point is to negotiate
um a treaty that is most beneficial to
you and you do that by negotiating wi
with each other's leaders. Okay? Because
they have the authority to implement the
treaty. That's the first reason. The
second reason is if you kill
the leader then more people there'll be
a competition to replace the leader.
Right? And during a gang war, the person
who is most violent, the most extreme
will often become the new leader. Okay?
So by killing this leader, not only do
you cause uh conflict among the gang,
but you also cause a massive escalation
and a conflict um between these two
gangs. And there's really no way out.
that that is why historically you do not
target other nations leaders because
then there's no off-ramp.
Okay. So by targeting um larjani the
Israelis and the Americans have ensured
that there will be no offramp. Now this
war we fought to the bitter end and
unfortunately as we discussed previously
that is the objective here. The Israelis
and the Americans are interested in
maximalist aims to destroy Iran
permanently. Okay? And the Iranians are
also maximist and that they want to
destroy the global economy permanently
in order to restructure reality itself.
All right. Okay. So this leaves us with
three major questions that I want to
look at today. Okay. The first big
question is
how
are these leaders dying?
It's not that easy to kill a leader,
right? Because he's protected by
security. And usually we there are two
ways to figure out where the leader is.
Okay? There's human intelligence
called humanit. And there's signal
intelligence called signant.
Okay? Human intelligence, signal
intelligence. Signal intelligence just
means electronic easedropping where I
listen in on your telephone calls where
I track your IP address. Okay. And the
Israelis Americans are obviously very
sophisticated in that. And the Americans
in the Israelis are saying we are using
electronic surveillance in order to
track these people down. I don't think
that's convincing. I think the most um
import the most important source the
most reliable source of information is
human intelligence. having spies
embedded in local networks to spot for
you where they are. Okay, that's the
most um that's the best way to figure
out where they are. So then this raises
the question, how are the Israelis and
Americans getting this human
intelligence? Okay. All right. That's
the first question we want to look at.
How are these leaders dying? Second
question is like why are they dying?
like what's the point of killing them,
right? Because once they die, they can
just be replaced and they're often
replaced by a more extreme
um individual. Okay, so that's the
second question we want to look at. And
the third question we want to look at is
what does this mean
for the war
and the world?
Okay. What do these decapitation strikes
ultimately mean for how this war will
progress and how this will affect the
world the world in general? Okay. All
right. So those those are the three big
questions I want to look at. So to
answer these three questions, I want to
introduce a new idea to you. Okay. It's
called the law of proximity.
The law of proximity. The idea is this.
Whenever you play a game, you're not
just playing one game. You're playing
many, many different games. And the game
that you choose to play is the one that
is most proximate to you, the one that
is close, most close to you. And that
impacts your decision-m the most. Okay,
so that's a lot of proximity. So let me
explain to you what this uh means using
an analogy. Okay, let's just use your
life. you are play actually multiple
games every single day. All right. So
let's let's examine this. The first game
you play of course is the family game,
right? So you might have uh parents
and you have siblings. Okay?
And the game you're playing of course is
to win attention from your parents. And
to do so, depending on who your siblings
are, you might use different strategies,
including doing well in school or being
a pain in the ass. Unfortunately, my
kids choose to be a pain in the ass.
Okay. Um, yes, the parents are playing
another game, which is
um social
um
um prestige, right? So, they're
competing against other parents to have
the best family possible. All right. So,
and then not only do you play a game at
at um home, but you also play games at
school, right? Right. So, when you go to
school, you're competing at your
classmates for attention and popularity,
but you're also playing um a game in the
school to get the best grades so that
you you can get into a good college,
right?
Then you go to work
where you're competing in order to win
the favor of your boss and to be popular
among your colleagues. Then you play a
city game where you live in Beijing and
you want Beijing to be better than maybe
Shanghai or Shenzhen. Okay? And then you
play a game of maybe a nation where you
want China to be stronger than Japan.
Okay? So as you can see every single day
you're playing multiple games even
though even though you may not recognize
it and again what's important is the
game that is most important to you is
the game which you are most close to
right the one that you can see in front
of you. Okay does that make sense? Okay.
But this is also true for nations as
well where we think that the game is
um between nations
but really the game is within nations
and the conflict within nations is the
one conflict that determines how nations
behave against each other. All right. So
we so today what we will do is we will
look at three examples of of this. Okay.
We will look at the civil conflicts in
America, in Israel and in Iran to figure
out why they behave the way they do and
then figure out how this war will
progress. Okay. So clearly there is a
civil conflict right now in America.
Okay. You have the Democrats
and you have the Republicans.
Now, what's odd is that even though
these two different political parties
are at war with each other, they both
support the war because their calculus
is different. Okay. So, why do the
Democrats support this war? Well, it's
because they believe
that this war will be extremely
unpopular in America, which will allow
the Democrats to dominate in the
midterms in November and then win the
president presidential election in 20 uh
28.
And they believe that this will be so
unpopular, it will destroy Donald Trump
and um allow Democrats to rule forever.
it will basically destroy the Republican
party. All right? And so that is your
strategy. And if you think about it, it
actually makes a lot of sense. The
Republicans have a different strategy,
which is this war may be unpopular
and this war
may um uh make America lose, but
it's okay. Why? Because in a time of
war, the president has something called
the emergency powers act. Okay?
Emergency powers.
Emergency powers allows the president to
essentially suspend the constitution and
to suspend or delay elections.
Also,
um the Republicans want to call pass
something called Safe America Act.
Okay. The Save America Act um which
means that if you are a voter you must
present ID in order to vote and you
think that this is um well reasonable.
But historically the idea of checking ID
is a way to discriminate against
minorities, right? to have police
officers there to scare uh minorities
and that's traditionally how um racism
was enforced in in America. Okay. So in
other words, the Republicans have many
different strategies of either cheating
or manipulating the elections. They can
also I have to say this but if the war
is going really badly what they will do
is call a national draft and cancel the
elections. Okay. All right. So these are
two different strategies going on. But
as you can see this is not really about
America defeating
Iran. This is really about the Democrats
or Republicans trying to
obtain power and keep it. Okay. All
right. But what's important for us to
understand is that it's not just about
the Democrats and Republicans at war
with each other. There's actually a much
deeper divide in America. Okay? And this
divide is a conflict between the
um elite
and the counter elite.
Remember how we introduced the idea of
elite over production, right? Uh this is
a Peter Turin idea.
And he argues that what leads to civil
war is that you have too much too many
elite who want to be the ones in power.
Power is a zero sum game. And therefore
when you have elite over production,
they have to go to war against each
other in order to um have the power.
Okay. And so what's going on? Who are
the elite and who's the counter lead?
Well, I mean to put it very simply, the
Democrats represent the elite and the
Republicans represent the counter elite.
Okay? So, um the basically the elite is
the empire
and counter elite is um MAGA which is
America first. And so they have two
different um um ideals for America. The
empire is to maintain a current global
order, right? and MAGA is to retreat
back into Western Hemisphere and focus
on um Americans core national interests,
right? They're also divided into finance
and um AI. Okay? So, in other words,
Wall Street are the main backers of the
current elite and then Silicon Valley
are the main backers of the counter uh
elite.
Okay. So this these people are
interested in maintaining a the status
quo.
They are interested in a revolution,
right? And so this is the main divide in
America that will eventually lead to a
civil war like like an actual civil war.
Okay? But right now um they're fighting
over foreign policy. So I will discuss
this more in um the future. Okay? But um
I want I present it to you now. So let
me give you concrete example of why
they're fighting. Why are people finance
fighting uh with people in AI? And
there's a very good reason because if
you're able to control Washington DC, if
you're able to control the levers of
government, you're able to make a lot of
money for yourself. Okay? So let's look
at this concretely.
Okay. What people don't really
understand is that both finance and AI
are bubbles that will burst. They're
parasites. Okay. So, finance um is a
parasite because there's something
called a private credit bubble. All
right?
Private credit bubble it I mean the idea
of private credit is very simple. Rather
than banks issuing loans to companies,
companies privately issue loans to other
companies. And you would think that
these companies would be very careful
with
who they lend to and how much they lend
to, right? That's not true though. Okay?
Why? Because in 20 2008, these banks
destroy the global economy and the
American government bailed them out,
right? They suffered no consequences.
This this idea of moral hazard. If you
do not suffer consequences for your
stupidity, well, you're just going to be
more stupid in the future. Okay? So
these companies believe that we control
Washington DC, therefore we can be as
risky and stupid as we want. So they're
giving out lots and lots of silly loans
to companies because they collect a fee
for these loans, right? And then when
these loans don't actually work out,
meaning the companies go bankrupt, what
they do is they say, "Oh, we we'll lend
you some more money to keep afloat."
Okay? So now this problem has reached
about $2 trillion.
And so they think that okay well worst
case scenario the government will bail
us out if we all go bankrupt because
we're too big to fail and all our
friends are in government.
Okay that's their mentality. And in 2008
that worked but there's a problem today
which is there's also another group
that's doing the same crap. Okay? And
it's called the AI bubble.
All right? So if you look at AI bubble,
you have you got companies like
Microsoft,
um Open AI, uh Oracle, Nvidia,
um okay, lot lots and lots of different
companies. And the way they operate is
they just lend money to each other.
Okay? It's like I give you a billion
dollars, then you give me a billion
dollars, and now we have $2 billion.
Okay? It's a circle jerk. And and it's
getting a lot of money from the GCC and
other investors. The problem of course
is what's happening in the war, right?
So if the GCC can no longer put more
money into this bubble, then eventually
this bubble will have to burst.
But they're like, that's okay. Why?
Because we control Trump. We control the
White House. We are the stock market.
Therefore, Washington DC will bail us
out. Okay? So that's the war going on
where you have two parasitic forces, the
finance sector and the and the tech
sector and there are all looking for
government bailouts when their bubble
burst. But they the government doesn't
have infinite money. It can only build
one side, right? So they're going to
fight over with the government they're
going to fight over who bails who out.
Okay? If the Democrats can win the House
and the presidency into 2028, then the
private credit people will get bailed
out. But if Trump and his people stay in
power in 2028, then the AI people will
get bailed out. Okay? So that's the
civil war going on in America uh right
now. We'll discuss this more later in
the future, but I just present to you uh
right now. Okay. And then of course you
have the um Israelis Israel people don't
really appreciate how divided
Israel is. This is about 2020 when you
have like a million people in Tel Aviv
calling for the resignation the
impeachment
uh the jailing of Prime Minister
Netanyahu
because Nanyahu like most Israeli
politicians is very corrupt. Okay. um
and to avoid going to jail, Nanyahu
proposed changing the judiciary,
changing changing the laws. And so
there's these massive protests against
Nanyahu. And at this point in Israel, um
it seemed as though Nanyahu was going to
fall from power and go to jail for the
rest of his life. But then of course
October 7th happened. Okay, October 7th
happened and then we Israel is now in
permanent war. That gives him emergency
powers. Okay. All right. To give you a
sense of how divided Israel is, let's
look at the Knesset, which is a
parliament. Guys, this is a lot of
political parties and as you can see,
none of them are dominant. Okay, the
biggest loot, which is Nanyahu party, it
has about 30 members, but it cannot rule
by itself. Therefore, it has to join
with other political parties. Okay? It
has to be a coalition. But look, you
look at its enemies. Well, its enemies
also have a lot. So, it seems as though
Israel is a extremely divided society,
and it is. Okay. People don't really
appreciate this. You know, a lot of
people talk about a Jewish global
conspiracy. What people don't really
understand is the Jewish people have
never ever gotten along. So, you go back
to the to the time of Jesus and there
were like three major factions in
Jerusalem. They were the Seduces, there
were the Pharisees and the Essenes. They
all hated each other. In in the year 70,
the Romans sent a huge army to destroy
Jerusalem. Okay? And you would think at
this time the people in Jerusalem would
get together and unite and defend
Jerusalem because otherwise they'd all
be killed.
Well, they didn't get together, okay?
And the Romans destroyed Jerusalem and
burned down the second temple and
massacred a lot of Jews. So the Jews
have always had this problem where
they're extremely creative and
intellectual, but that just leads to
massive infighting. Okay.
All right. So these are the leaders of
uh the different political parties of
Israel. And again, I hate to say this,
but like they really hate each other.
It's not, you know, like a show. They
generally hate each other. And that's
why um Israel has been politically been
so dysfunctional these past few decades.
Okay. All right. So now I I want to
discuss
where the major conflict in Israel is.
Okay. So I would say there like the two
major conflict is represented by
Tel Aviv
and Jerusalem.
These are two cities in Israel and they
are the two major cities of Israel and
they represent two different centers of
gravity, two different visions for
Israel. Uh Tel Aviv is democratic.
Jerusalem is a theocracy meaning it's
it's religious. Okay. Uh Tel Aviv is um
open
meaning it actually has a lot of
homosexuals, right? And you can imagine
people in Jerusalem aren't happy about
this. So they're very conservative.
Okay.
Okay. Cosmopolitan
uh tradition. All right. So these are
two vastly different uh visions of for
Israel where Tel Aviv is is this open
democratic modern progressive city. lots
of homosexuals, lots of open ideas, very
secular, very outward-looking, very
western. Jerusalem is complete opposite,
okay? Very religious, very conservative.
And they again, they hate each other.
And the fact that Tel Aviv is getting
destroyed right now in this war, people
in Jerusalem are actually okay with
this, okay? They're not like, "Oh my
god, they're killing." No, no, no. Tel
Aviv is the great Satan. Let's just
destroy it so that we can um build a
theocracy. Okay. All right. So,
let's look closely at where they where
they disagree. Okay. So, Israel is a
kingdom of David.
Okay. But Tel Aviv and Jerusalem
perceive David differently. Okay. So,
for people in Tel Aviv, David was the
king when Israel was at the height of
its glory. when it was an open
cosmopolitan
creative innovative empire and that's
what they want Issue to be. The people
in Jerusalem see this see David as a
different person. They see David as
primarily a um
uh poet prophet
and they see David as the exampler
as the favorite of God because he
redeemed himself and repented himself in
the eyes of God. Okay. So redemption
and repentance. All right.
And what they focus on is a story of
David where David is king and one day he
wakes up and finds he's in love with
Bashiba.
And so he basically has sex with
Bashiba. Bashiba gets pregnant and
that's a problem because Bashibba is
married to someone else, Yuria the
Hitite. So what does David do? David has
him killed. Okay. And David can do this
because he's king. But God finds out and
sends the prophet Nathan to tell David,
you've sinned. And at first, David
refuses to admit that he's in a wrong.
But then their son, his child with
Bashibba dies, and David falls into
tremendous grief. And every day he's
praying to God for forgiveness. He's
asking for redemption. He is repenting.
And God forgives him. And in this
process, not only does David become a
better person, but he becomes
united with God because now they're best
friends. Now they talk every day. And
that's what the vision for that people
in Jerusalem have for Israel, a nation
that engages in redemption and
repentance. They don't care about this
war. Don't care about Iran. They don't
care about the United States. Don't care
about the Israel project. They care
about the Jews finding God again and
being loyal to God. And that is what
will bring peace to the world. Okay,
that is how they see the world. This is
how how they perceive things. They they
believe that in every person there's a
divine soul, okay, that comes from God,
but it is it is trapped in the animal
soul. Okay, so Tel Aviv is the animal
soul.
And this is divine soul.
All right. So what the animal soul is,
you seek material comfort. You want to
have sex. You want to get drunk. You
want to party. You want to drive a drive
a Ferrari. Okay? This is all animal.
But inside of you is the vine soul that
only seeks to be with God. Okay? And so
we are constant in a struggle between
the animal soul and the divine soul.
And so from their perspective, Tel Aviv
represents the animal soul of Israel.
Jerusalem represents the divine soul of
Israel. So it's okay if there is destroy
Tel Aviv. Good. Also they recognize that
war is good because if people really
want to find God again, they need to
suffer. They need they need to lose
everything before they recognize the
glory of God. Okay. So, think of um the
book of Job
when Job was Job is a character in the
Bible who's very wealthy and and so God
decides, you know what, maybe he's only
faithful to me because he's very
wealthy. So, Job lose everything and
this heightens his faith in God. Okay.
So that's the vision that these crazy
religious zealots have in Jerusalem,
which is like let's destroy Israel so
that we can refine,
rediscover
our love for God. Okay? The destruction
of Israel will lead to the redemption
and repetence of the Israeli people and
therefore peace in this world. The
Messiah will finally come. That's why
the rabbi was constantly talking about
um on Thursday Messiah will come because
he feels it's so close. There's so much
destruction. There's so much war. So the
Messiah must come because now the Jews
recognize that only God can save them.
Therefore, when you will it, when you
pray for the Messiah, when you really
want in your heart, that's when the
Messiah will come. Okay? But you need to
create the conditions when people really
want the Messiah. Okay? So that's a
civil conflict going on in um Israel.
And again,
these people in Jerusalem, these
fanatics, they don't really care if the
the world is destroyed because this
world is fake anyway. Who cares? What
matters is the divine soul. Okay.
Yeah. Um you have a question. Um M
>> like you said that Messiah is coming
today which is Thursday and like
>> No, I didn't say that.
>> Huh?
>> I didn't say that. The rabbi said that.
>> Oh the the rabbi said that like the
Messiah is coming today. But like will
the coming of Messiah really affect
China and those countries or is uh all
their personal beliefs?
>> Okay, listen. I I know this is hard for
you guys to understand but China doesn't
matter. Okay? Only Israel matters.
United States, China, Russia does not
matter. The only thing that matters is
Israel. Okay? Only matters is the people
in Israel, the Jews.
Their spiritual state will determine the
fate of the world. Once the Jews
um unify with God, then peace and
prosperity will come for the rest of the
world. Okay?
All right.
Okay. So, um, now I want to talk about
Iran. Okay. This is the political
government structure of Iran. Now, one
thing to notice is that it's very
complicated. Okay. It's divided into the
religious aspects okay assembly of
experts and the secular aspect which is
um the um
um government okay so it's a government
but the Islamic clerics are at the very
top and this is a dual identity of Iran
okay and
this is the uh their last presidential
election and as you can see it's It's a
pretty divided country where people in
the middle voted for Jalali
but people in the outskirts voted for uh
peskin. Okay.
So there's a lot of conflict in Iran not
just political religious but also ethnic
as well. All right. So so let me explain
very quickly what I see is a major
divide
in Iran. Okay. So, of course, you have
um the Islamic theocracy.
Another conflict with um secular
nationalists.
And now, of course, there ethnic groups
as well.
I don't really think the ethnic groups
matter that much. Okay. what really
matters is a conflict between the
secular nationalists and the Islamic
theocracy. Right? So basically the rural
urban divide. Uh people who are well
educated and want to see Iran as a
secular state that promotes democracy
and progress and science versus these um
religious individuals. Okay. Now what
happens is that in a war
um you become more extreme. So what will
happen is that is this theocracy will
transition into Shia
esquetology
or martyrdom. Okay. where they think
that this war is about return having the
12th IM
Madi who is the basically the Messiah
return to lead them to war against the
great Satan which is Israel in the
United States. Okay. So over time uh the
Islamists will become much more radical.
This will force the secular nationalist
to also become much more radical as
well. So they will become Persian
exceptionalists. Okay. What this is
means is that
Persian exceptionalism which just means
that Persia
is the greatest civilization in human
history and therefore it is worth dying
for. It is worth fighting for. The
survival of the Persian civilization is
much more important than the survival of
the Iranian state. Okay. So the great
question for the Iranians is are they
able to reconcile the differences
between these two strands of the culture
or will this lead to civil war in Iran?
Okay. Um we are seeing civil war in
Israel. We're seeing civil war in
America.
Iran cannot afford to fight a civil war
at this time because they're being
bombarded by two very popular nations,
the the Israel and America. Okay. But
unfortunately, the law of proximity
teaches us that people are much more
interested in their own internal
conflict than the outside global
conflict. Okay. And so this
understanding
now gives us
um helps us answer the three big
questions of today, right? How are these
leaders getting killed? Why are they
getting killed? And what will this mean
for the rest of the world? Okay. And so
the first two questions, how are they
getting killed? Why are they getting
killed? They're getting killed because
of all these civil conflicts within
these nations. Okay. these different
factions are providing intelligence to
their enemies in order to limit their
internal enemies. Right? That's again I
don't have evidence but I think
according to game theory that's the best
explanation for how these leaders are
getting killed because again it's not
that easy as a foreign nation to
identify
the location precisely of that leader.
Okay. And what we're seeing in this war
is both the Iranians and the Israelis
are doing a very excellent job of
killing each other's leaders. And that's
not actually common, right? So I think
this civil conflict within these nations
offers the best guide, the best
understanding of why this of why this
happened. Okay. The third question is
where's the where's the uh world going?
As you can see from these conflicts,
um it seems as though the world can only
become much more theocratic in the end.
Okay. So, what's happening is at the end
of the day, this war in Iran uh in the
Middle East, it's really a war between
two different competing visions of the
world. Okay? you f you have the global
secular
financial order.
Okay? And this is the world that we live
in today. And they're fighting against a
nationalist
theocracy,
theocratic order. All right. So this is
what we can expect over the next 5 to 10
years where Iran becomes much more
theocratic and extreme and
nationalistic.
Israel abandons democracy and embraces
theocracy. America will also abandon
democracy and embrace theocracy because
that is a general trend of the world.
Okay.
All right. Okay. So um what I want to do
next class is discuss how the world will
change next 5 to 10 years. All right.
Okay. Any questions?
Okay.
I mentioned that Israel have um two
divided parts and one represents the
animal soul and the other represents the
divine soul. Like I I can substitute
this logic to a a single person like
like people are always struggled with
like identify or not identify like
separating the divine soul and pursue
the divine soul but they cannot get rid
of the animal soul. Is there a way where
we can only struggle at as in our lives?
>> Okay. So first of all, it's important to
understand that that this is how
religious people in Israel frame
the um conflict in Israel. Okay? What a
conflict between the animal soul and the
vine soul. Um the people in Tel Aviv
would frame the debate as one between
progress and tradition, right? Going
forward or staying backward, right? So,
so um that is uh so people in Tel Aviv
and Judism would would see this in a in
a different way. Um but as you point
out, there's some validity to this idea
that we're all struggle uh between the
animal soul and the divine soul. And I
would say that for the past 20 years, we
only have been indulging in the animal
soul. Okay? We've abandoned the divine
soul. And that's why I think people are
so desperate for
uh change and and this is what's leading
to so much conflict around the world
where the human soul is is off balance.
Okay? Where we are too materialistic and
not spiritual enough. And what we know
from history is that if you if a a
society goes too far in one extreme,
they swim back to the extreme. Okay? And
that's what we're seeing where um one
good outcome I think of all this
conflict around the world is people
start to recognize the limitations of
money of materialism of individualism
and they start to embrace more
spirituality community because quite
honestly you don't have a choice in the
matter. Okay. If you if you're like, you
know, I want to buy myself a Gulfream
jet and I want to have like, you know,
um a huge company, you're you're you're
going to be disappointed. Okay. Um
as I will show you next class, um the
world is headed towards an economic
depression. Okay. Basically a a
splintering, a rupture in the world. And
so you're not going to able to to afford
to fly to Mald for vacation. There will
be avocados in the supermarket. Okay?
But that this this but all this means is
now you have a chance to focus more on
introspection, on reflection, on family,
on asking yourself what makes me happy,
what gives me meaning and purpose in
life. And the answer of course is each
other. Okay? And maybe this is a good
thing. Maybe this is the intention of
the universe. Maybe as the people in
Jerusalem would say, this is really the
plan of God.
Okay? And I it's unfortunate that all
this war and suffering is happening. But
again, what a lot of people who are
religious will tell you is we can only
find redemption through suffering and
through pain and through tragedy.
All right. Okay.
Any more questions, guys?
Okay. All right. I'll see you uh next